We come to pulling ears — a very,
very important manoeuvre. We can fold in right and left
surface — first of all,
little-ears. With little-ears pulled and
accelerator, we achieve sink rates of 3
to a maximum of 3.7 metres, 3.7 metres
per second sink, but we fly
straight ahead. That means we can still
do forward flight, so for example
to fly out of some area we want to
escape. So very effective and very good and
very simple. That's why, when we pull the
ears, as you can already
notice — anything that collapses brakes first of all
the wing. If you look at it from the side,
by pulling the ears we have now
reduced glide. We brake the wing
right and left on the outer wing
a bit. That means, angle of attack
now increases somewhat. Now that's
a bit bad for us, because with the increased
angle of attack, we've of course become slower.
Through the smaller
surface we have an increased wing loading —
our weight has of course stayed the same.
That means weight per square metre of surface
is much greater than before. That also means
that the stall point — the point where we
stop the wing from flying forward — has also
moved upward. So it's gotten earlier.
I'll just give an example — it doesn't match reality,
but just so you can follow
the whole thing a bit. With the wing open we're
at the stall point of 18 to 20 km/h, with
ears pulled and greater wing loading
we're at 23 to 25 km/h. But now we've become
slower, through the increased angle of attack.
That means, our window — which before was so big
to the stall point — has now gotten smaller.
So the stall is
much more easily possible. On top of that it's often the case that
we want to pump the ears a bit
open and the stall is simply much more quickly present.
Combined with, for example, thermals, that would also be
fatal. For this reason, in our
school pulling ears is always done only in combination with the
accelerator. Because through accelerating
I tilt the cap further down at the front, I
decrease the angle of attack. I even increase
the sink rate further. And now I'm with
my, or my stall window — that's now again somewhat
bigger. I have again more distance to the stall point.
And that's why with us pulling ears is always only in
combination with the accelerator. Good, we'll do the whole pulling-ears thing.
Actually very simple. We keep the brake handles
in our hand. We get the accelerator ready,
if you don't get into the accelerator easily, you can take the
brakes into one hand if you then get the
accelerator ready. Then the brakes go back into the
respective hand. Then step on the accelerator again,
so that with both legs we stand nicely symmetrically slightly in
it, 30 to 40 percent. Now we try to orient ourselves.
We look for the outermost A-line. It goes on its
own, simply far out to the wing.
But doesn't go to the wingtip of the wing. That would be the
stabilo, the cathedral wing.
We go onto the wing.
But doesn't go to the wingtip of the wing.
We do the whole thing — step on the accelerator, so that on one
wing. Then the brake handles go, which are in the hand
to orient yourself. Then we go to the wing.
We want to be on the other side roughly on the application
So on one all the lines were red, and the stabilo line on the B-level was also red, so
not very smart. That's why try to really orient yourself — it has to be the outermost
A-line. On A-wings that's always hung up alone. So you see one line
hangs alone on a line lock and is even led alone to one riser.
This is often even marked with a little flag or a different colour. So
that should also make the whole thing a bit easier for you — finding this line. Then to grab this line
and fold in the surface above, you have to hold it like this: with the thumb and
the index finger above these lines. And now it's important — count in your head. We
want to pull symmetrically, that means count in your head, 1, 22, 22, 23 pull the line down and now
so that the line doesn't uncontrolled, snap back up, we hold this to the
main riser, where they can be. And when we have that, with a look up
see, hey-ho, we've cleanly tucked the ears, then we apply full gas, that means full
accelerator. Now we can steer, only with weight shift. And with
harnesses with a seat board that works very, very well. With harnesses without a seat board we can, if
that's not enough, the weight shift, by pulling on the inner riser, so
really transition, and lean weight onto it, we can bring the wing even better around the corner.
To exit, neutral position, go back a bit out of the gas,
just not too much, about 50 percent. Then let the lines release symmetrically up
free. If the ears are still in, that means it's important to look at the wing — if the
ears are still in, then we let the accelerator go and pump once strongly,
remember the same load, that's why prepare the accelerator inside. Then pump once,
if the ears are out, we can go out, if the ears still stay in,
then count in your head, 21, 22 and only two to three seconds later comes
one strong pump and then we go out. Good, that's it for pulling ears.